la parole est à notre collègue alain
marc
pour le grossiste solide anglicane vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue la
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre je souhaite une fois n'est pas
coutume monsieur le premier ministre
vous féliciter d'avoir entendu le
président du sénat et notre groupe qui
ces derniers jours ont attiré votre
attention sur le caractère illisible et
sur les conséquences inconnues de la
réforme de la dgf que votre gouvernement
souhaite proposer à la baisse brutale
des dotations des collectivités vous
souhaitez y ajouter à coût constant
une réforme de la dgf sans être en
mesure de fournir des simulations
exploitables une réforme de cette
ampleur ne peut pas passer en douce ses
conséquences doivent être claires et
expliquer aujourd'hui bien que vous ayez
reporter l'application de cette réforme
vous souhaitez que ces grands principes
soit arrêtée dès le projet de loi des
finances 2016 alors de deux choses l'une
où il y à des incertitudes sur les
conséquences de ce texte et je vois mal
comment les parlementaires pourraient se
prononcer en connaissance de cause ou
vous estimez qu'il n'y en a pas et je
vois mal le sens de votre report votre
position monsieur le premier ministre ne
répond à aucune logique
la réforme la dgf est un sujet
suffisamment important pour faire
l'objet d'une loi autonome c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous vous demandons
de tirer toutes les conséquence de
l'incapacité du gouvernement à fournir
des simulations fiable à reprendre
entièrement le processus de réformes et
à organiser un grand et vrai débat sur
ce sujet autrement que dans l'urgence
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement
engagé une réforme de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement des communes
et les intercommunalités
vous le savez vous le rappeliez dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finances pour
2016 la mission conduite par christine
pires bonnet par votre très regretté
collègue jean germain a établi un
diagnostic comment nous pourrions
partager issues d'une large concertation
avec les élus et depuis longtemps et
l'ensemble des associations d'élus
qui conclut à ce que la dgf est
profondément injuste et je veux de
nouveau salué la qualité de ce travail
qui a permis d'engager la discussion sur
des bases solides travail que marylise
lebranchu andré vallini ou christian
eckert ont poursuivi la dgf est donc
injuste et inéquitable et les par
ailleurs illisible la réforme que nous
souhaitons et que beaucoup d'élus sur
tous les bancs souhaite répond me
semble-t-il à trois objectifs d'abord
une meilleure lisibilité de la dgf avec
une architecture qui soient plus claires
une dotation de base égale pour chaque
commune et des dotations complémentaires
pour tenir compte des charges de
ruralité ou des charges de centralité et
puis nous avons deux autres objectifs de
justice
appelons-la territoriale réduire les
écarts de dotation justifié et accentuer
les effets de la péréquation
cet objectif je crois là aussi tout lé
monde tout le monde les partages alors
une réforme est nécessaire pour rétablir
de l'équité et de la justice dans
l'attribution des ressources des
collectivités qui font un effort qui
participe par ailleurs à l'effort de
lutte contre les déficits le public mais
parce que cette réforme est importante
parce que elle doit s'inscrire dans la
durée
parce que nous voulons faire
différemment de ceux qui ont fait la
réforme sur la taxe professionnelle sans
simulation sans simulation rapidement et
imposer nous voulons prendre le temps
nécessaire et j'ai entendu les arguments
à la fois des parlementaires de la
majorité comme de l'opposition et de
l'ensemble des grandes associations
d'élus
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé que
nous devrions voter les principes pour
marquer la volonté de nous inscrire dans
cette réforme de la mettre en oeuvre au
1er janvier 2010 est pourquoi ce qu'il y
a un argument qui devrait s'imposer à
chacun bien sûr
il ya encore un travail de simulation à
faire même si je dois dire que la dgcl
bercy les cabinets des ministres que
j'ai cités il y un instant on fait un
effort considérable et permettent
d'avoir des éléments déjà de très grande
qualité pour pouvoir travailler mais il
faut continuer à travailler notamment
dans la durée par rapport au budget
pluriannuel mais il ya un autre élément
qui m'a été rappelé par de nombreux
présidents d'associations
d'intercommunalité ou d'élus c'est que
la carte intercommunale sera achevée le
31 mars 2016 et c'est sur c'est pour ces
raisons mais je vais dans le sens de ce
que beaucoup d'élus attendaient c'est
pour cette raison que au mois d'avril
sur la base de cette nouvelle carte
intercommunale la précision nécessaire
qui aura été requise d'ici là nous
pourrons à ce moment là boucler cette
réforme de la dgf et l'inscrire
pleinement dans la loi de finances 2010
est ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
réforme maintenant soit engagée qu'elle
s'inscrive dans la durée
qu'elle puisse se faire sur des bases de
très grande transparence
nous réformons nous réformons nos
territoires nous réformons la fiscalité
locale
les dotations aux collectivités
territoriales il y aura une majorité de
gagnant il peut y avoir je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce mot de perdants non il ya
plus de gagnants que de perdants
et c'est une manière et c'est une
manière mais ne polémiquent est pas le
polémique et pas de manière absurde
n'utilisons pas ce sujet là à des fins
politiques
alors que je suis en train de vous dire
que je suis dans l' écoute et nous
sommes en train de travailler à une
réforme durable et que nous faisons
exactement le contraire de ce que vous
avez fait pour ce qui concerne la taxe
professionnelle veuillez l'entendre une
nouvelle fois donc une réforme juste une
réforme juste sous présent et une
réforme équitable
une réforme qui s'inscrit dans la durée
et le réforme lisible pour l'ensemble
des élus locaux
voudriez d'accord et applaudir deux fois
que communiste merci tu as la marque
pour 40 secondes
monsieur le premier ministre vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que
les collectivités locales porte 70% de
l'investissement public aujourd'hui avec
la baisse des dotations de l'état avec
des réformes comme celle des rythmes
scolaires
cette capacité d'investissement
s'amenuisent or avec une nouvelle dgf
celle ci doit être partagé par tous les
pas leurs parlementaires et élaboré par
eux donc elle doit faire l'objet à mon
avis de l'avis du président du sénat
d'une loi spécifique
c'est ce à quoi je vous engage pour les
semaines et les mois à venir reconnaît
le prévenu très court un j'équilibre les
règles du jeu lesieu qu'on lui dise je
le respecte je n'ai pas encore monsieur
le président envoyait mais je le faire
bientôt un courrier à l'ensemble des
maires de france
un mot monsieur le sénateur
un mot sur les dotations monsieur le
sénateur mettez vous d'accord avec vos
amis quand on demande de réduire les
déficits publics de 100 à 150 milliards
supplémentaires il faut dire qu'ils ça
concernera et vous le savez ça
concernera aussi les collectivités